my identity is not my obstacle  my identity is my superpower I am just  one of millions of people who have been  told that in order to fulfill my dreams  in order to contribute my talents to the  world I have to resist the truth of who  I am I for one am ready to stop  resisting  and to start existing  as my full and authentic self in spite  of what I had been told my whole life  I saw firsthand that my unrealistic  expectations to see myself authentically  represented in the culture were other  people's expectations too collectively  we are what the world actually looks  like and in order for our systems to  reflect that they don't have to create a  new reality they just have to stop  resisting the one we already live in